retour à Pep effectivement nous sommes
en direct dans la voie libre dans ce
petit village de Haute-Saône au confins
de nos deux régions entre la Bourgogne
et la France-Comté on parle évidemment
de la fusion des régions de ce projet en
cours avec les deux présidents des
Conseils Régionaux actuellement du fait
la présidente de France compter et
François Patriat le président du conseil
régional de Bourgogne et Lilian dans
cette deuxième partie on va parler
politique alors aussi avec les questions
que les internautes ont posé parce que
pendant l'émission il y a eu un certain
nombre de questions qui que vous avez vu
à l'antenne continuer d'ailleurs bien
sûr de poser vos questions alors avant
de faire vraiment de la Vilaine
politique moi j'avais envie parce que
pour tout vous dire juste avant le
générique de l'émission Marie guide du
fait a crié parce qu'on parlait capitale
des régions on disait en plaisantant que
il y a certaines régions François
patrial disait ou finalement le problème
de la capitale se pose pas et je vous ai
remarqué fioleusement Marie guide du
fait que finalement ici on dit qu'il y a
pas vraiment de problème parce que
personne veut vraiment le dire où elle
sera cette capitale et vous vous êtes
mis en colère
j'ai réagi parce que je vous ai expliqué
qu'effectivement c'était un problème que
personne ne le niait mais que on
répondait effectivement par la
construction de quelque chose qui est
nouveau parce qu'il n'y a pas de
métropole dans cette région et qu'il y a
un construire quelque chose d'équilibré
entre Dijon et Besançon qui sont deux
villes qui n'ont pas ni l'un ni l'autre
la taille d'une métropole en Auvergne la
question ne se pose pas
entre Clermont-Ferrand et Lyon parce que
Lyon effectivement est une métropole par
rapport à Clermont-Ferrand mais là où
j'ai réagi c'est que je vous ai dit
qu'il fallait construire quelque chose
de nouveau et vous m'avez dit ça c'est
pour ne pas répondre mais j'y crois
fondamentalement nous avons un projet
politique à bâtir et ce qui est
intéressant dans cette réforme des
régions c'est pas la question de l'Union
administrative c'est le projet politique
à construire peut être plus fort et pour
répondre mieux aux besoins des habitants
et cette question elle existe et elle
sera travaillée dans l'harmonie où sera
le conseil régional je vous ai répondu
il sera peut-être à Besançon et la
préfecture peut-être à Dijon et
vice-versa nous sommes en train de
porter un amendement
que le siège du Conseil régional n'est
pas forcément le lieu le siège du
chef-lieu c'est-à-dire la préfecture
il avait été proposé notamment par un
député de Besançon en première lecture à
l'Assemblée Éric alozé absolument parce
que nous travaillons de concert là avec
le député byzantin avec le maire de
Besançon et cette question voilà elle
est en train d'être travaillée le siège
du Conseil régional pourra être distinct
de celui de la préfecture et l'un et
l'autre être alternatif être l'un à
Dijon l'autre a Besançon alors puisqu'on
parlé du Sénat et de ce qui peut s'y
discuter François Patriat on a parlé des
régions comme la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté qui sont en plein travail
de de mariage il y a des régions qui
vont rien avoir à faire aussi on a on a
tendance à l'oublier alors peut-être
même plus qu'on ne le croyait si
effectivement l'Alsace reste de son côté
et que que Languedoc-Roussillon reste
aussi de son côté par ailleurs
mais ça veut dire que vous vous aurez
des difficultés ça va vous coûter de
l'argent pendant région elle n'auront
rien à faire est-ce que il y a une aide
qui va se faire est-ce qu'il y a quelque
chose qui est prévu là-dedans c'est une
question que j'ai soulevé au Sénat cette
semaine il y aura effectivement deux
types de régions celles qui vont avancer
au fil de l'eau j'ai pas tout à l'heure
de PACA par exemple qui vont continuer
comme elle était aujourd'hui et celles
qui vont avoir un fusionner qui vont
avoir demain à régler tous leurs
problèmes internes j'ai pas dit que ce
serait coûteux parce que la preuve
demain on aura un seul recteur un seul
préfet de région une seule DREAL on aura
tout ça demain avec des services
décentralisés donc on va quand même
faire des économies et on va clarifier
mais il reste que j'ai demandé à l'état
j'ai demandé au Premier ministre de
prendre en compte cette difficulté
qu'auront les régions à elle avancée pas
plus doucement mais à se restructurer il
y aura deux ou trois ans de travail pour
y arriver si le 3 ans ça mérite un bonus
un bonus financier dans nos projets dans
nos contrats de plans qui sont encore en
discussion aujourd'hui je vais demander
nous en avons obtenu pour partie
notamment déjà sur
l'université sur la recherche
l'enseignement supérieur poursuivre nous
devons un bonus pour pouvoir nous
permettre
d'investir dans le même temps et de ne
pas être retardé par nos mécaniques
internes sauf erreur de ma part François
Patriat c'était le projet initial les
régions volontaristes auront des aides
financières arcantel fusionneront pour
celles qui veulent rester entre elles
voilà on garde la situation actuelle le
problème c'est que ça a été la fusion
des régions a été généralisée finalement
et là où vous avez été peut-être vous
aviez pris de l'avance et puis
finalement tout le monde doit s'y mettre
donc voilà alors j'ai introduit au Sénat
un amendement de préfiguration celui les
régions en préfiguration doivent
aujourd'hui bénéficier d'un amendement
d'un complément d'aide de l'État ça peut
être une aide immatériale ça peut être
une matérielle ça peut être une aide
financière pour y arriver je compte bien
que nous puissions y arriver
Maggie du fait de façon plus prosaïque
on disait tout à l'heure que la
politique est faite de symboles on
parlait de on parlait de capital il va
aussi avoir des élections pour ces cette
future grande région on parlait de
dynamisme démocratique tout à l'heure
avec François Berthelon est-ce que vous
savez tous les deux comment ça va se
passer est-ce qu'on connaît le mode de
scrutin de des élections de ces
nouvelles grandes régions est-ce que
vous avez des détails là-dessus pour
l'instant on en a pas trop les élections
auront lieu sur périmètre élargi le
périmètre de la Grande Région donc ça
c'est quand même fondamentalement
nouveau autrement ce sera le même mode
d'élection une seule liste pour
l'ensemble de la Grande Région non on a
des listes par département elle est là
il aura donc huit sections
départementales au lieu de 4
la date n'est pas encore bien stabilisée
j'entends aussi des projets sur début
donc tout cela a besoin d'être fortement
stabilisé pour qu'on y voit clair et que
l'on prenne des décisions en conséquence
on meurt d'envie de vous la poser la
question vous êtes tous les deux
présidents de conseil régionaux est-ce
que vous serez candidat dans ces
élections Marie Guy dufec et François
Patriot
moi pour l'instant je ne me pose pas la
question j'ai toujours dit à ceux qui me
la pose ainsi qu'à mes collaborateurs
que le temps viendrait de la décision et
que ce temps ce serait en début d'année
prochaine aujourd'hui je me suis
consacrée à mettre tous mes moyens pour
que cette réforme qui est un acte
volontariste et courageux du
gouvernement prennent corps dans notre
dans notre territoire la question de
l'après je me la poserai en temps voulu
mais les choses ne sont pas assez
stables et précises pour que je puisse
apporter une autre réponse François
Patriat même question vous serez leur
candidat le mode de scrutin les dates la
candidature
mode de scrutin le mode de scrutin
actuel est un mode de scrutin qui
fonctionne assez bien et qui a résolu le
problème des alliances contre nature
c'est un mode de scrutin Raffarin 2004
il a été il sera conservé la date moi je
suis pour repousser la date non pas pour
prolonger mon mandat croyez pas cela je
suis pour que nous fassions des
élections dans la clarté dans la clarté
dans la simplification
si les deux textes sont pas votés avant
le mois de mars je vois mal comment vont
se dérouler des campagnes sur les
cantonales départementales avec des
compétences qui n'ont été votées qu'en
première lecture qui seront sujettes à
évolution ensuite ça va être une source
de difficulté je souhaite que les deux
textes
celui sur les limites et sur lui sur les
compétences soit votées avant qu'on
aille en campagne électorale pour que
les citoyens sachent sur quoi ils vont
décider donc moi je suis pour un report
deux buts 2016 au maximum des élections
en décembre mais décembre n'est pas une
bonne période pour les élections très
bien donc début 2016 cantonal et
régional c'est le terme échu normal des
élections telles qu'elles avaient été
avant sur la candidature
j'ai dit que je ne mentalise rien alors
je vais pas vous évoquer la possibilité
du binôme comme pour les cantonales on
pourrait faire rapidement c'est pas hors
de question il y aura une présidente ou
un président
le problème qui se pose dans cette
candidature c'est que la loi sur le
cumul tombe en 2017 2017 que vous êtes
très élu sénateur donc je m'interroge
sur la pertinence d'une double
candidature pour l'instant ce que je
vous Marie vous dire
aujourd'hui c'est que je ne m'interdis
rien je peux bien entendu être candidat
mais quoi qu'il arrive la seule réponse
que j'ai c'est que je ferai tout parce
que la majorité reste la majorité est-ce
qu'il y aura une typologie particulière
pour les gens qui vont mener les listes
parce que on va se retrouver avec une
campagne à faire dans des départements
nouveaux en fait où les gens ne vous
connaissent pas forcément est-ce que
est-ce qu'on en parle déjà dans les dans
la sphère politique de tout ça Marie
guide du fait non non aujourd'hui on en
parle pas mais on commence à se poser
des questions effectivement et il va
falloir qu'on imagine une campagne
différente mais là même si on peut pas
parler de binôme parce qu'effectivement
il y en a un ou une qui conduira la
liste on va travailler en binôme et en
binôme si c'est un franc-comtois qui
tire la liste il aura assez coté un
second bourguignon qu'il aidera à
connaître la Bourgogne et aller au
contact des Bourguignons et vice-versa
et vice-versa mais bon voilà cela va
nécessiter de la discussion entre nous
qui n'a pas commencé mais qui ne pose
pas de problème a priori vous ferez
campagne les uns les autres alors je
précise parce qu'on parle de la
candidature socialiste je précise que
François Sauvadet à droite
udi a fait acte de candidature il y a
quelques jours
on est tous d'accord oui bon voilà pour
l'état des candidatures mais
ça voudra dire quoi une grande région en
décembre 2015 quel qu'est-ce que ce sera
concrètement est-ce qu'il y aura des
projets communs est-ce qu'il y aura déjà
des décisions d'implantation du conseil
régional vous avez parlé du rectorat de
voilà c'est ce sera quoi la région au
moment de la campagne à ce moment-là
alors la fusion elle sera concrète le
premier janvier 2016 donc tout commence
après le premier janvier 2016 c'est à
dire qu'au moment des élections en
théorie rien n'a commencé sauf que chez
nous Bourgogne Franche-Comté tout a
commencé puisque nous avons une
quinzaine de chantiers pour faire con
pour ne pas se réguler au verger
complètement nos politiques nos services
et que quand vous parlez de projet je
pense que c'est effectivement très
fédérateur de dire pour cette future
grande région quel projet nouveau et
nous nous sommes mis d'accord François
Patriat et moi pour que ce soit sur la
question de la transition énergétique
que nous ayons des projets fédérateurs
nouveaux et nous les aurons pour la
campagne électorale parce que des
janvier février nous nous mettons en
situation
de réunir nos élus régionaux et les élus
du Césaire sur cette question de la
transition énergétique et des projets
que nous pourrions porter à l'avenir
Bourgogne franchement compter
on parle de ce qui va être fait moi je
vais casser une ambiance en parlant de
ceux qui voudraient s'en aller on sait
qu'il y a un certain nombre de débats a
eu lieu et a toujours lieu sur un centre
de départements qu'ils disent est-ce
qu'on sera bien est-ce que ce sera bien
notre place c'est ce qu'on appelle c'est
en discussion en ce moment au Parlement
c'est ce qu'on appelle le droit
d'options la possibilité de s'en aller
ou de pas s'en aller on va dire que
globalement la position du gouvernement
c'est que le droit d'option il soit
aller quasiment impossible puisqu'il
faudrait que la région de départ donne
son accord est-ce que c'est
voilà justement
qui reçoit
et les trois cinquièmes dans le
département qui veut partir
des élus du conseil régional
pour ce qui est de la région de départ
il faut qu'elle réunissent les 315
contre donc c'est un peu assoupli là
difficile de votre point de vue bien
entendu là le droit d'option c'est 2019
ce que j'ai d'abord il ne se pose pas
pour beaucoup de départements de nos
deux régions pour un quel pouvait penser
le territoire
pour lequel il se pose il reste que
d'ici là la fusion sera déjà trois ans
est-ce que si on a fait la démonstration
que nos dirigions sont capables de
coopérer et quand vous posez la question
tout à l'heure comment les choses
avancent nous réfléchissons aujourd'hui
à un contrat de plan commun que du coup
construisons nous réfléchissons
aujourd'hui à un futur budget commun les
choses ont déjà avancé les choses ont
déjà
s'en aller
comme on est bien chez nous après tout
la Franche-Comté est tellement nouvelle
la Bourgogne est tellement belle
pourquoi est-ce qu'on reste pas ensemble
l'idée c'est d'essayer de désamorcer
cette envie de rejoindre à notre
territoire je ne sais pas cette envie
est très répandue sur le territoire de
Belfort parce que jusqu'à maintenant je
suis allé quand même beaucoup au contact
de la population dans le Territoire de
Belfort ce n'est pas ce que j'ai entendu
ni de la part des habitants ni de la
part des acteurs économiques pour pour
lesquels
voilà mais peut-être que certains élus
le souhaitent je ne vois pas les
habitants la population le souhaitait
massivement écoutez on va terminer
là-dessus j'en profite juste pour dire
que justement la semaine prochaine dans
la voie est libre et bien on parlera de
l'avenir du Territoire de Belfort la
voie libre en Franche-Comté Lilian et en
Bourgogne ce sera sur le futur parc
national des forêts de Bourgogne et de
et de champagne voilà bon très bien
merci en tout cas à tous les deux
d'avoir participé à cette émission merci
à vous de nous avoir suivis profitez
bien de votre weekend à bientôt